As much as we have concerns over GPU and CPU bottlenecks, bandwidth is also a considerable
concern in larger multiplayer games. One vital tool at our disposal is managing relevancy.
Relevancy is the umbrella term used to describe how we determine what data is sent
to what clients, so what governs whether or not their data is relevant.
For instance if a bullet is fired on the other side of the world, does my local
client need to know about it? I'm too far away for it to hit me, and I'm too far
away to hear it, and I'm definitely too far away to see its visual effects. In this regard
we can manage the bullet's relevancy in such a way that we can skip sending the bullet
over the network entirely, avoiding the needless bandwidth consumption.
If an actor spends too long out of relevancy it will be destroyed, following the same
destruction logic we'd experience if we called destroy directly. When it re-enters
relevancy, it'll have its begin play called, as if it's been respawned back into
the game. It's worth noting that relevancy works on an actor level, so we can't
set a single component to have independent relevancy rules.
Relevancy is primarily distance based, so simply put, it's something too far away
from my local client to care. By default, Unreal considers one and a half
kilometres too far to be relevant, but that's entirely configurable inside the
actor class defaults under the net call distance squared parameter.
There's a few instances where we might want to disable relevancy checks entirely,
and set is always relevant to true in the class defaults. Typically we'll use this
when developing networked services that should always be accessible to every
client, but this is of course down to your particular project specifications.
An example of an always relevant actor in vanilla Unreal, however, would be the
game state. It's just a replicated actor that every client needs to know
about, regardless of their current circumstances. Similarly, we might want to
enable be always relevant to owner. In this scenario, if we take ownership of
something that's too far away, it'll send its data over the network to us.
In some circumstances, distance is too broad of a metric to define whether or
not something is relevant to the client. We can override the isNetRelevantFor
function in the actor to create a custom implementation. So for instance,
we may want to say that our actor is only relevant to players assigned to
certain teams. If we override the isNetRelevantFor function to only
return true when we have a team ID match, we will only send data to that
particular player. Whilst distance is a primary means of detecting relevancy
for actors, Unreal will also make an actor irrelevant if the root scene component of an
actor is hidden and its collision is turned off. While relevancy decides
whether or not we should send the data, dormancy controls whether or not we
should even try and send the data. So let's give ourselves a practical
example and see how dormant and awake dormancy settings would actually
play out. So let's say we've got a cube in the viewport and it's always
relevant. Let's also say that the server is changing its color once a second.
Given what we already know, we'd expect there to be hundreds of net updates
constantly checking to see if the value on the client matches what the server
thinks. So in this case, is the server's color the same as the client's color?
When we have a mismatch, the new color is sent over the network,
triggering an on rep, hooking into our color change logic. That's a lot of
work for something we know is only going to change once a second. If we change
our actor's dormancy setting to dormant, we can all but eliminate those
needless net updates by telling the engine directly, hey, I've changed
something, please propagate it down to the client for me. All we need to do is
call flush net dormancy once we've made a change that we expect to replicate.
For this single update, we'll treat this actor as if it's totally active
and liable to all the usual relevancy checks. Once we've propagated everything
down, the actor will return to its dormant state and await another flush
to be triggered by the developer. You should really consider dormancy when
implementing network features that only need to replicate their properties
when specifically told to do so. So for instance, say we've got a door that
can be opened or locked. Once it's unlocked, we can set the B is open
bool to true and call flush net dormancy. So we don't need to keep
checking the state of B is open on the client. As engineers, we know
it's only going to change when we specifically tell it to.